OK, we have a voicemail number, that number
is two one nine two David P. Here is a of
increasingly popular question about Trump
and his relationship to Twitter after he's
no longer president.
And I had a quick question.
So with the recent news about Donald Trump's
Twitter account, getting those little information
labels underneath is disproven tweets.
And then recently he was almost Sokoloff where
people couldn't reply to this tweet.
Right.
Because when do you think that he eventually
wants he's no longer president?
Do you think that Twitter is going to be in
his account?
And if so, do you think he's going to just
try and make a new one?
Or do you think he's going to try to use social
media sites such as Denna, which has more
of an all right leaning user base?
Yeah, I think that there's a really good chance
Trump gets banned from Twitter when he's no
longer president.
We've talked already about Section 230.
We talked about Trump losing world leader
protections on January 20th.
And I do think that if it happens, it will
be a boon for whatever platform Trump chooses
to promote that he's switching over to.
And there's a bunch of different people.
You know, there's parler, there's all these
different all these different platforms.
I think the day Trump gets banned from Twitter,
if it happens and it's announced, join us
over on this other app that is going to be
a golden golden day for for whichever app
Donald Trump switches to.
But, yeah, I think the risk of banning being
banned from Twitter is really high.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We have a California sheriff refusing to comply
with an order to release certain inmates due
to covid.
How is that going to shake out?
Who's going to win that?
Wall Street has started to trade water futures
as a commodity.
I've been warning about this for a decade.
And we're going to have a discussion about
the potential for future water wars.
And then I want to talk a little bit about
the 80 million Americans who chose not to
vote at all in this past election.
Why didn't they vote?
NPR did a very interesting investigation and
story about the 80 million who did not vote
in this past election.
And we will talk about that as well.
Get instant access to today's bonus show,
where I will be joined by producer Pat by
signing up at Join Pakman dot com.
If you would like a discount, I have a discount
available.
It's with the coupon code fresh start.
All one word, all lowercase, no space.
Fresh start saves you bigly money dollars
bigly money dollars to be saved using the
coupon code.
Fresh start.
I'll see you on the bonus check.